welcome Nick depalo do you know who kid
I don't hi this is Nick what's up
my you know who's not going to put on we
were talking hook before you got in
about uh uh like white guys and even if
they're rich and celebrities who put on
like the black scent oh God how much we
hate that yeah hate it hate it what is
that black scent when guys white guys
act when they when they talk one way and
then they talk to a black yo what up kid
yeah thank you Nick don't look like that
kind of guy that's not me at all you're
right yeah Jim are you surprised Nick
toala didn't come in and go yo who kid
what up Al I kind of did a little that
last night the stand I gotta be honest
did you well yeah this black guy I I
haven't been in there in a [__] year
and again they all blend into me so uh I
just what up [__] you know the
[__] 9 Minute handshake and then I'm
like then I who's that oh
Derek what do I know how many artists
how many um celebrities has been on the
show that act black cuz I'm black a lot
I mean I've been I've seen it we don't
see it though because they're not in
with us right they don't act black when
they're with us right but I've seen it
cuz like I'll I'll I'll interview them
and then they'll go and do your show and
I'll sit in on your show and I'll watch
them just be a totally different person
you didn't talk like that around me what
are you talking like that for and I talk
like this like like I'm as white as can
be yeah well not as white as well mik
Tyson who K I could tell you a black if
I was on the phone with you you could a
for real a little bit not but not heavy
you're right you're not right he brought
us t the first time he said he would and
he did I couldn't believe it and Mike
Tyson said that you were the whitest
black guy he knew I think he phrased it
differently that's right so you're
superlative you're a
superlative my [__] Andrew uh H Andrew
Schultz was in here uh early this
morning because he's doing swayed show
today should I know him and he he yeah
[__] I don't follow Show Business honest
to God he's a fellow comedian who had a
Nick depalo Story oh I like that kid
yeah yeah the funny kid Chappelle he was
talking yeah he said that Chappelle was
telling a story about you about how he
was doing a a some show and you guys
were all doing it in LA and it was it
the the the disabled comic yeah that a
disabled comic uh is on stage and he's
killing he did like 10 minutes and he's
like severely disabled was missing arms
and [__] I don't know not missing
anything but none of it worked might as
well have been missing it right it was
all useless yeah it was all
Aesthetics yeah his
props so I H him out dead
arm all man that's horrible is it so
Nick Nick goes up there and then you
know people are like well how's how's
Nick can handle this this guy just
killed and now Nick's got to follow it
okay so apparently Nick did about 10
minutes straight of just a disabled
person comedy that was bombing like some
heartless [__] oh yeah yeah just totally
heartless
[__] some and it was a McDonald's
[__] reference and
oh but came with a helmet working at
McDonald's cuz that was hey grety can I
get a f of fish or something with
something like that and that was
supposed to you know rip the tits off
the crowd I could crickets some oh here
we go and instead of abandoning that I'm
like [__] these I you know kept digging
the whole dat burn date burn people
enjoyed it well yeah that's what like
when you bomb like that do you be like
okay I got to win this crowd back or
okay [__] if you thought that was bad
wait till I got well that's you know
Jimmy right there's nights where you're
like I'm not [__] you people right if
you do it long enough and he'll tell you
this if you do it long enough bombing
the even the silence is almost as good
as to laugh some if I'm if I'm in a bad
mood and they hate me it's uh you can't
lose right it depends on what I did a
cancer benefit where I open with a c
like the joke I open with oh no come on
no no but I did some joke about killing
or something and whatever and it it got
a zero and I immediately knew it was
like one of two things but I was like it
was just it wasn't a great joke so I
couldn't tell if they would just being
sensitive it was just not a great joke
so I just went into my I tried one
regular joke and it worked so I was like
okay right it was they were they were
fine terrible joke but you smelled this
hint of like this could go really wrong
you don't want to bomb add a cancer
benefit cuz you did cancer joke like I
just didn't I didn't have enough good
cancer jokes to to justify it I just had
one shitty one but I love that that
happens in comedy when you're in a bad
mood like who kid like if you're in a
bad mood you're not just going to play
like shitty music that nobody dances to
right like if if you're DJing a club
you're not just going to play what they
don't want to hear I had to DJ one of
those uh what you call it handicap
parties like I don't know what they're
called it it was for a charity but it
was all handicap it was like a thousand
like disable called the benefit for
cripples how you how you say how you say
[__] politically Sam Roberts I don't
think that's the correct terminology
physically challenged that's it thank we
always go to Nick talo to get the
mentally or physically challenged that's
right challenge like it's a game show
it's funny your legs don't work get over
right yeah no matter how you're not
beating that challenge buddy you're not
winning this one you're not going to
overcome these these [__] gave
me a list of songs I couldn't play at
the cuz you know if you play certain
hype songs they can't control them cuz
it's only like 30 disorder oh so they're
like so they're like mentally challenged
I come play All I do is win cuz they be
whing I just go [__] crazy go crazy
man oh my God can't play all I'm going
to do is zoom zoom zoom cuz I'll be
yelling at for 3 weeks I mean they
retards got strength Ian I mean not
[__] I'm buing mentally challeng I'm
from the 80s man I still say [__] man
me too in the
mirror I do too I'm not letting that
word go I call my father that my I've
called I said this on stage I've used a
[__] a thousand times I don't think
I've ever called the gay guy [__]
it's my brother you know my [__]
father right right who is gay by the way
I think it's like it's a it's a funny
word and you know from everybody said it
I just love that you're you're dealing
with a bunch of people and that's really
like how they're caring for the mentally
challenged like look we don't want to
play anything that like is too upbeat
because we won't be able to control them
like you might like you're drugging them
and not letting them hear certain music
going crazy and then and I played it by
mistake it was over like they were body
slamming people in white you know they
wear all the white suits and stuff right
body slamming [__]
everywhere I didn't realize they were
still uh caring for them like that the
orderlies were coming in and just like
C's n yeah knocking them out fight you
still don't know where you are do you
McMurphy and and they they really whack
off like randomly like there's no sexual
stuff going on but they whack off they
masturbating I guess I'm mentally
challenged ain't no wrong being a [__]
you're just pulling them out nothing's
wrong with me stop it man pulling him
out did you see anybody jerking off
while you were uh they told me that cuz
I was DJing I was in a corner don't be
alarmed they may start masturbating yeah
somebody throws something at you it's
not tapioca don't eat
it I didn't and I didn't know there was
a [__] social media I was in all the
[__] Instagrams and all the what do
you mean what what is is it their own
like uh it's with uh that 50 Tyson guy I
had to do a charity he's like mentally
but he looks like 50 s
Tyson what but he's like 50 Tyson oh the
rapper guy the guy who uh who come on
Sam you know this [__] the guy who does
the D nuts jokes and goes got him no no
not that
[__] [__] he's kind of [__]
though right this one looks like 50 Cent
and Tyson mixed oh let me see is it this
guy 10 million view Tyson the model no
that's a fighter the video is called 50
Tyson yeah that's him he calls himself
50 Tyson cuz he's 50 mixed with Mike
Tyson Tyson Tyson say but but it's like
man hit me up though my album is coming
out in stores pleasy soon go get it up
and then it's going to be popping though
know what I'm saying but I know you see
man
translator it's going to be popping
though you know what I'm saying I call
myself 40 butter
Fuko it's the Long Island
version
well that was what he does look holy
[__] yeah he do holy Christ sent in Mike
Tyson how's his album yeah did we did
you manage to pick up a copy of his
album uh no oh okay he opens with people
who need people it's really song OD song
choices but but they think he's like
he's like the most famous artist in that
handicap world is he handicapped yeah
he's handicapped too he's mentally
challenged whatever you guys are saying
did you yeah did you it's hard to tell
sometimes yeah he doesn't seem he seems
not in this case I don't think I'm not
like he gets his dick me that could be
Kanye he gets his dicks think that could
be Kanye yeah oh [__] well yeah he could
be that he crazy too that's he crazy too
man he's crazy too
though that sh is a bunch of [__]
did you hear about right you're
absolutely right K what are you talking
about Nick he's going through severe
depression he's he's exhausted yeah he's
exhausted he work so hard I love that
you know what working hard is when you
come with you know it's like [__]
you're working on your music you're
smoking weed hang out with 12 guys right
then you go look at the shoes you
designed for a half hour say hi again
then you [__] one of the Kardashians
that's an 18-hour work day is it am
right Jimmy yeah is it shoes you
designed or is it shoes you approved the
design of that's the one that's my shoe
yeah they have foot models come in and
he lays there picking him out you that's
how I see it you're a cool white guy
would you wear a $2,500 pair of shoes
from Kanye West uh I don't know depends
what they look like that would be great
but I'm not going to wear them in the
Bronx I feel like I I feel like I would
hit all spectrums if I was wearing my uh
Nick Apollo podcast t-shirt and
Yeezys covering the end of the spe
that's right and just letting everybody
know like hey it's it's all it's all
good that's right from head to toe he's
tired he's had a very Tucker out tour
and uh just the way he [__] his fans
constantly walking off after three songs
like what a [__] that's crazy unless
he's mentally ill like unless there's
something genuinely wrong with him I The
Comedy Works did you no why oh I was
tired I was exhausted you did one joke
and said [__] every you people two Jews
walk into a bar I need a nap good
night don't bring up the
juice yeah I want you guys to know I
would have voted for Donald Trump and
I'm leaving what okay fine he's doing by
the way his concert 90 minutes done in
and out it's not like it's just
exhausted it's 90 minutes lot of energy
have you seen him he really runs around
out there yeah I mean look a very small
stage what is he do I couldn't name a
[__] I just see his face I want to
punch it he's actually musically decent
I
mean people I hear that from people who
know say he really is good but does I
think he's gay number one don't you uh
well I've heard specul I think I think
his brother's like brother it runs into
a
family mean your brother's gay you gay I
don't know I hope you can get it on you
I hope not yeah I have a gay brother I
hope
not
[__] said was a [__] when I first no
it doesn't years ago I don't think it
always runs like that yeah it does it's
a
lateral yeah yeah the uh uh so Kanye and
it's not it's people were saying it's a
publicity stun he canceled like 30 shows
that's a lot of money and this is like
when you start [__] with like Ticket
Master and venues well they get mad at
you oh they get mad yeah he must be
having
he's having a breakdown he said like I
know but he like uh yeah so he canceled
all his shows he walked off after three
songs then he canceled the rest of them
how much is he worth already Sam guy's
worth about $2 million 2 million could
be more probably more could be more okay
no but they caught him with the um the
food stamp card he has an EBT card yeah
they caught him with it get out of here
yeah and he checked in as a different
name in the hotel Jim Jones no the name
he bro you think I'm making this this
part of the breakdown he just had you
mean or this a while ago when they when
they arrested him they checked his ID he
had a food stamp card does he have an
Obama phone too I don't know about that
yeah food stamp c gu's a zillionaire
[__] married to zillionaire yeah I
don't know what that is you know I got
I'm a rich [__] man I don't know you
operate mainly in cash do you really ha
spend in cash Kanye is like uh Kim is
the government cheese here [__]
starving up here DJ who kid accepts
poola on his radio show so that's that's
done in cash so he's then got a oh you
do Peola get be careful so what would po
be how does it work theyig could pay me
I'll play it oh to play music yeah but
in layman's
terms explain to me especially if you
hear I'm saying yo this song is extra
hot smoothness to it that Billy D
Williams [__] right they know I'm
lying and I got paid I see yeah they
they can tell by the way yeah yeah how
much did it cost uh probably like three
to five depends on how horrible the song
is if it's really bad have you played
some no a thousand no to play it once no
who kid is hot in these streets I don't
know if you know this or not I have no
doubt that that's how well that was our
business the Italians with the pay and
play yeah and the Jews you know I
learned from you've seen The Sopranos
right of course and the they the ones
who Hesh that's right yeah but I didn't
know was that much three or 5,000 play
once I mean if you got 7 million
[__] smok of weed and drugs and
[__] with far condoms they're tuned
in and you play one song they not going
to we should you know what we should do
we should start seeing if we can charge
some of these open micers to come and
sit in here yeah 1500 we'll laugh at all
your [__]
yeah I can set that up for yall man no
matter how bad the jokes are we'll go
crazy yeah I got a lot of corny homies
that you know what people would do that
though anyway and how what can the
signal to the audience be How about if
Samurai at the end go
you'll know we got paid and that we we
were winking at you if we go and uh and
y'all can check him
we I can't believe Sam never did that no
I've always worked you it's harder to do
and talk plus yeah people pay attention
to what we're doing you under the rad
I'm so paranoid I can't even think of
like any type of pay for play just
[__] freaks me out just stop to the
song you go kaching it's easy you meet
them they pay you and you laugh that's
it yeah and you play and Comics are do
that if you did that tomorrow I'm
telling you coms have a line of [__]
oh my God they're the most desperate
people in the world I so dirty doing
that though yeah let's do it I'd feel
very Italian you would do you would do
it as a young as a kid though right if
you had the
money I don't know would young Jim
Norton do it I don't know if I had an
attraction I remember I did radio with a
guy my buddy Frank deliso and I was my
first time doing radio and I was
terrible at it and uh we were in the it
was like an afternoon show that South
Jersey Frank was very popular and I
didn't know what to say on the radio
from Jersey yeah yeah he was very
popular and he said uh I wasn't saying
anything at the mic he go say hello Jim
and I hello Jim oh no
yeah wow looks like we really do got a
comedian in the room yeah [__]
boola then he threw hot coffee in your
face on
here you you guys are really crazy cuz
we all have Ferraris we be shopping at
Lou and all that [__] but you know what
they find out though and you get [__]
comedians are blabbermouths the
comedians would tell they do a bit on it
you could you could get on this radio
show it's only 1500 bucks you could do
the show no they say it on the show yeah
they go can I do my Peola chunk I wrote
yeah but they'd say hey no laughs I'm
paying for this and they like three or
four big mouth comedians say it's it's
true though because now even more than
like when you guys were coming up way
more I think people want to be famous
and there's a lot of people that try
comedy that you know aren't going to
stick around but they just want but you
everyone talks now with social media the
first joke you didn't laugh at that blow
you up I paid money what you let him do
[__]
I guess I don't have the money to get on
the show oh comedians would [__]
snitch in a second yeah they'd be ticked
off wouldn't they yeah you don't want a
bunch of [__] pissed off comedians
that's the last thing we need Toc
cocksuck is all of us yeah plus it
probably be like Nick Nick would be like
hey guys I need to promote this thing ah
we got a guy paying to come in so we're
gonna bump you Nick oh [__] you or if we
couldn't have him in because we were off
what he got on on Twitter what you got
someone paying you [__] no on today it's
Sunday look I only drw 1% of what the
the record labels pay they paid 250
Grand to get their song spent well
that's one of the no for how many what
there got to be a rotation time a month
or what I mean I've known artists they
had like $400,000 budgets for their
singles to blow up on was the
terrestrial radio that's what Kanye
right before his breakdown he was
interrupting that's how you know he's
having a breakdown too I saw him at the
beginning of his tour when he was at the
Garden and it was awesome all music no
interruptions no rants you went and saw
Kanye nothing I love Kanye do you yeah
musically you know yeah so when he just
does a show and when he just does his
songs and when he performs awesome great
but when he starts to and then as the
tour went on he talked a
little a little more and that's when
like two days before he canceled all the
tours he just start going [__] radio who
by the way radio plays Kanye all the
time you know who gave him he go [__]
radio he goes I like Drake but they Play
Drake Too Much I said [__] radio to my
agent Tony Burton about a year ago
that was for different reasons so he uh
yeah he's really he's really I saw a
good interview with him there's a guy at
you know Charlamagne he does uh
Charlamagne the God I don't know what
UHF Breakfast Club and he gave him a
really honest interview like I don't
know what their relationship is but he
was telling him like what he liked about
him and like some of the stuff that he
didn't like it was a really honest and
Kanye responded to the honesty like he
didn't he didn't walk out I mean he took
the guy telling him he didn't like his
stuff like you know he he he dealt with
it he's got to be he's I I think he's
nuts I think he is too he's just a
little a little nuts a little just
enough to I think but I was some of it
seemed uh forced to contrive L you know
in the hospital with [__] I don't know
but but losing all these gigs canceling
a massive tour A Ticket Master and the
venue [__] Live Nation that's a
problem not like he's [__] himself
though that's that's where I draw the
line that's
the cuz he did on on this tour he had a
floating stage that moved yeah so like
he had people under him the whole time
when he's peeing on him and stuff how
great would it be he just bend he just
squats and starts [__] on his fans
what does he do I mean I saw it he just
walks back in Forth like yeah it's like
a little it's a it's a little stage and
it's hard work hanging from the ceiling
you think it's you think it's exhausting
he's saying it's he's tired as [__] he's
tethered into the stage the whole time
so you think that's the problem he's
tired as [__] tired ASU he's probably
tense all the time like that's not easy
to manage that kind of stuff but you
just got to finish your tour and shut up
just finish the [__] tour for
Christ's sake Stephen Hawkins doing
linkoln commercials [__] how tough can
it be good point or whatever the [__]
then again how much he does what does he
jagar he doesn't exercise just kind of
sits there nothing butt time let's see
stepen Hawking prants around tired of to
write a bit about that we need somebody
who enjoys a smooth ride easy
handling all these things well you going
blame me because of Kanye because you
know I was the last person that was with
him and I told him he
sucked car yeah I'm dead ass oh yeah who
kid's got a good story about like I
found the video too it on my I put it up
yeah put it up today DJ hook on today I
put it out like a couple days ago but
okay so search his history or whatever
because you know Kanye has been
complaining since the beginning and he
said in the very beginning and I talked
you know who Jensen karp is yes yeah you
don't who the fu no you don't Jensen
carp he he he had phones there's a
furniture store called Jensen Lewis here
that he's tied in with
got I knew you had to work at car s on
that sofa [__] different guy
Jensen carp yeah running back isn't he
for the
Eagles he's like this white guy Jenny
carp and ended up out of college getting
a big uh recording contract A hip-hop
guy well he's not really a hip-hop guy
no he's white but but they they gave him
a million-dollar record contract and he
was this white rapper and now he's just
a who gave it to him uh was it
like one of one of the big names or no
one of the big record labels yeah sh
take it is that but he knew like he was
working with Kanye right before he was
famous well oh that's him right there
that's J Kanye wow Kanye looks young
there who's the guy in the right that's
that's him that's J what year is that
like 96 95 or is that no it's it's it's
later Jen carp does look like he has no
musical ability 99 2000 yeah his arm
should be Harrier Jesus Christ yeah
looks like he's got Sarah Silverman's
arm you know what he does now ouch he
writes the uh the rap battles for uh
what's his name's Tv show uh the fat guy
on CBS uh
are still friends the late nighty F Guy
Tom celic yeah Tom you know the the the
guy who does the Late Night show Cordon
James Cordon oh the gay guy yeah yeah he
does he writes the rap battles for James
Cordon show now W I bet [__] parents
are proud that guy stepped in Gold
though
I Karaoke what you do with a [__]
garbage
truck [__] you're sick of it h neck
it's actually cool that part that's the
only part of the show um I'm sure he's a
nice fellow oh that's a cool stage yeah
that's terrific what's he on a panini
maker the [__] is that what the [__]
he standing on it's like a mattress
commercial he's talking about Kanye's
stage that's a lot of H look at that I
wouldn't want to be under that a pan a
panini maker look at this guy that's how
I had that I had that at the Comedy
Works in Denver that's how I came on is
that right yeah they lowered me down
like [__] Kanye so no they didn't got
guy who ruins the bit guy
with that's too small you like my wife
that didn't happen but Jensen Park was
was was working with him when Kanye was
just a producer before he was a rapper
you're like [__] Casey kasm here I
know all the musical history I wish he
was exactly like Casey KAS dead in the
ground yes fighting over no Sam knows
all the [__] so this kid was what he was
a white rapper he had a big deal yeah
yeah yeah and Kanye was producing for
him but he said even back then Kanye
would come in making beats for all the
rappers and try to get everybody to
listen to his music like I rap too these
are my rap songs B and everybody was
just like he [__] sucks like they all
made fun of him he would leave the room
and everybody would be like can you
believe he's [__] playing this [__]
again sucks and then what was his big
break he was finger popping him behind a
[__] dumpster well I went through
that same [__] too but I had
ludicrous in the studio and then
ludicrous was like yo I came here you
stupid [__] to do you a song and who's
this dumb [__] in there rapping in the
booth I said that I don't know him
that's Kanye West my label signed him to
do your beat uhhuh so he's in there yeah
1 plus 1 equals 2 Boo Boo Boo like so
he's s so he's supposed to just be there
to make the instrumental for ludicrous
but Luda is there so he's going crazy
like it's like Michael Jackson walked in
or something and then he just went nuts
like he's a groupy so he went in a boo
to rap for oh so Kanye gets excited oh
he likes ludicrous K gets excited cuz
ludicrous is there sure and just runs
into ludicrous is Studio yeah that's
like me starts rapping when I met
Michael Jackson yeah I came but I
understand but but you're not going to
start moonwalking that's cuz he was
sucking your dick
though I plead the
fifth I'm not gay though that's Michael
yo you know say no it's not gay if you
let M tune on
it that's just good business sense yeah
king of Po absolutely historical [__]
right there je well anyway you were way
too old for him so I ran in there and I
and I cursed him out was like yo what
the [__] you doing the [__] up go do the
beat for Luda so he goes back out there
and Luda picks another beat don't even
pick his beat yeah so then he's Furious
oh he doesn't pick the Kanye West how
was the song that ludicrous how was the
eventual song um some [__] about uh
sucking some titty some dumb song
dumback S I think I know that one yes
Andy Williams covered on the Christmas
album it was really bad I don't know I
leaked it though suck a titty Super
Friends sucking a titty on Christmas Eve
so I I told this I told this [__] guy
wait outside I'll film you because I was
doing a DVD at that time so I filmed him
outside whil lud was doing the sucking
titty song uhuh he's out there like
getting filmed by me I had to interview
to calm him down cuz if he if he knew
that I was filming him and I'm going to
put it out right then he's like oh [__]
I'm going to be famous so he said
everything he wanted to be famous so bad
this is like 12 years ago he said
everything in that in that video I'm
going to be with Jay-Z I'm going to do
Beats for him everybody's going to be on
my dick this before he was before oh wow
okay and I found this old tape and it
was in it you know the old cassette
tapes I pop out the camera I had to get
it like converted all kind of stupid
[__] but did you tell him he was you
told him he was good no I told him he
suck and then he got even more mad and I
and I shot him outside in the BMW oh no
I didn't hear about that yeah oh sorry I
know always gun playay yeah story is
done the same really breaking The
Stereotype there who kid gay man yeah so
uh have you seen him since then yeah of
course many times oh okay you're still
friends Kardashian are like the homies
you know what I'm saying like you know
but the thing that's crazy he shared a
tour bus with Chloe Kardashian I love
Chloe she's sexy right yeah I like Chloe
too J's daughter right there you know
what I'm saying yeah she was cool as
[__] but he flipped the car and then he
he came out with Through the Wire and he
blew up after that so I got the phone
call like an hour later oh who kid you
know he flipped his car he in the
hospital I was like that same night what
yeah that's hilarious it's crazy he
flipped his car he broke his jaw his
mouth was wired shut he recorded a song
he wrapped a song with his mouth wired
just a line from a song just now the way
you deliver
that how much would you have hated me if
I started how [__] fat was he look at
him yo that's that's an actual photo cuz
he's all swelled up wait his name should
be Kanye East and West I mean Jesus for
Pete's sake the guy's as chubby as
chubby can be he was going west in the
east lane wow look at that face that's
literally what he get hit with a
Vaseline bottle [__] Breezy
[__] yeah turn turn the heat
down in his room must be 110 it's like
an aola victim in the same Hospital
Tupac was in you know was it was it real
wow he broke his jaw and then wrapped
with his jaw broken well he fli he he
did a yeah he did one song called
Through the Wire and that blew him up
with his jaw wired shut pretty cool and
that was his biggest we hear that does
it sound like his jaw's broken you could
yeah you can tell my jaw's broken I
can't really
swallow that's not what he you like me
on Twitter feel free to
follow he do look like he's sweating
though though that wasn't bad that's a
that's a good thing right there I got an
album I got an album called through the
catheter all right tra white guy in his
50s I see you guys are looking at me
like hey man this guy looks like he
can't chew gum for
nothing that's actually yeah great
material thank you very much I've been
told I have really nice teeth thank the
good Lord that's a cute teeth right
there thank you very much you're kind of
slipping into a bad jany Carson again I
can't help it I don't know who Jenny
Carson is good Lord two Jews walk into a
bar good stuff good stuff
wild please don't bring up Johnny Carson
again cuz you know me man oh you
wouldn't hear Johnny Carson this [__]
[__] so like this is like maybe this is
two years ago Johnny Carson we get a a
Johnny Carson book sent to the studio or
whatever cuz whoever wrote it wants to
be a guest on yeah H kid walks into the
office wait a minute that was his lawyer
right Bush Henry bushin who we interview
oh yes that was the book hook walks into
the it's like two years ago probably
hook walks into the office picks up the
book he's like oh [__] Johnny Carson's
coming up here oh no I don't think so
who can he left the Tonight Show in 93
he's dead passed away he dead now yeah
he's and then who kid went down the he's
like no you're [__] with me and he
actually went down the hall asking
people is Johnny Carson really dead yeah
he's
dead you guys get all the great guests
and you always got a [__] not the dead
ones the cor you always got a corny book
from them before they come up here you
got to read that [__] which you usually
don't you read the forward yeah exactly
whatever in the dust jacket so once I
saw that yo I went
crazy yeah he's dead who yeah we don't
get all the good dead ones why I had to
find that on air though he's passed away
well I thought that was the better place
to let you know
empa he died from what empis he's a bad
he smoked for many many years and he
said he was retired he was very private
he jumped off his boat he like a nice
boat did he have a heart attack on the
water Jim no no he didn't no he uh but
he was swimming a little bit like he
just and he said when he came up he went
underwater and he realized he couldn't
catch his breath when he came up and
that was when he first knew something
was wrong with him uh he died in
2005 who kid 2005 where you die from
Kanye W Kanye West hit him with his
car so you don't you you don't feel
sympathy for Kanye's exhaustion no I
don't know again working hard you know I
mean he's in a coal mine [__] 18
hours a day Real by [__] looking at
[__] you know beats and suing on
joints and designing shoes like I said
how come you're not exhausted DJ who kid
you're on tour you're on tour with Waka
Flocka Flame and he he was running for
president see next time I see him I'm
going to call him kid who I'm G to [__]
it all up seriously that's what I was
going to call him like two seconds ago
said who kid who I got to get him to
hang with me man you know having orgies
is I mean I'm not going to complain I
could be tired from that are you having
orgies yeah do you guys have orgies
after comedy shows yeah with [__]
60-year-old maid at the Red Roof in and
her sister her sister carita
I Jer oh go ahead no go ahead I think I
was just I jerk off with eating pretzels
with the opener that's all I could think
of he had a better more specific one's
no way about pretz yeah but yours is
more realistic I actually had women in
mine thank you who gets on tour with
Waka Flocka Flame oh I like them and
they've done I like them flame is I like
Le zeppel I
like lead Zeppelin yeah I like him I
like lead he's a good guy do you meet
gals after that huh girls come back guy
Coursey how old are you who kid 45 the
[__] out of right a stereotype that's
also why he wears that hat though cuz
let me tell you something oh no l gossip
dreads LeBron James
baby I got Italy James but here's where
Waka Flaka and hookit are geniuses they
don't tour like hip-hop venues and stuff
they do like nonurban baby yeah
non-urban like fraternities and
sororities and stuff they just go to
venues with a whole bunch of White
Chicks oh God and they God bless you
they do like EDM hip-hop mixes you know
what I mean so it's all dance I don't
know what you mean wait what was the one
that he wouldn't do wasn't the one he
canel then which one did he cancel
because of the racist uh it was the bus
one college day the kids was Walling out
or some [__] like that but he's been
back since has he girls like him give a
[__] the check went through flame yo the
girl suck his penis huh do girl suck his
penis uh well you know he's married oh
but I mean would they if single this I
mean you know I was talk for him but if
he were
single right there he [__] everything
is that WKA floger or is that a strong
safety for the
Broncos looks like every NFL draftman
right there you know what I'm saying
yeah he just got a lot of Rich German at
him oh he he was drafted in the second
round but he killed his girlfriend with
a butter dish two weeks ago he's going
to Dro three notches yeah that's Waka I
mean I went through like at least a
couple hundred chicks and we I think
last week was our 210th show I want to
get on I need a rap tour look at how we
pil chick last week see this you got
your comedy yeah but no one [__] me
after it the H on those girls we call
that the moisture pyramid is that you by
the way you know what my favorite thing
who kid did was he calls that the
moisture pyramid right where he gets a
bunch of uh [__] to to No Shame by the
way no shame respectable wom respectable
[__] to to I just got turned on by that
cartoone you put up was that an actual
draw that was no that was that was a
real photo that's got to be a filter
yeah but it was like he piles them up
and they're all in short shorts so you
know how uh hes look good you know how
Amy SCH this country Amy Schumer likes
to do the human pyramid yeah and you
know how after her show that we went to
at the Garden she had Madonna there and
they all did the human pyramid hook
could took the photo off her Instagram
and went lol now Amy Schumer and Madonna
are doing the moisture pyramid I love
holy [__] you're ground breaker there's
nothing else for me to do in this [__]
that's your [__] right yeah [__] [__]
contributing to black people yeah I'm
good the mo the moist you appear
nightmare out there every day is like
20,000 10,000 thousand could be
different crowd a lot of nice rumps in
there though you think so but it ends in
like head jobs and if I hung out with
you guys at a show even if I didn't do
anything if I was just there you think I
can me a girl yeah yeah you get to get a
girl regardless you think so why don't
you [__] introduce me to wff and uh I
I hang out with you guys one night and I
get blown nobody calls him wff I'm
trying to sound a little [__]
I thought that was a
wrestling WKA fla flame oh [__] yeah he
can't do that can he I bet you he'll
love that I I think wff WF he would
actually like that probably you think so
yeah he likes where white people be
jumping around him and stuff he does he
likes crazy white people okay but how
about this sounds too much like a
Wrestling Federation okay I I I'll I
don't know him but I I'll just hang out
one time and then you can [__]
introduce me to some girls I don't know
who I'd be just get cornrows Jimmy in my
hair's too gray I would look awful yeah
You' be the like the the corro guy with
cancer be funny who would you introduce
me as if I hung out with you guys after
at a college didn't you have a didn't
you have a rap
name yeah did I kid kid
come there's two m not
gay I thought you had a rap name like
when you used to dress in like uh in in
your your Kangal hats and stuff I don't
remember I don't remember either tell
the truth but oh Jrock that'd be my name
oh no do you like that easy Jizzy that's
Kendrick lon's homeboy J Jrock that's
you and uh waka faka this guyy the man
right here yeah he's a big guy how tall
is he like 6'2 yeah he's pretty tall
almost seven he's not seven feet tall
he's a big guy he's a big [__] dude's
a big guy yeah we introduce me to him
and tell him look I just want to hang on
a little bit I don't want any money I
don't need any drugs I just want to hang
out and [__] uh meet a girl eat an
ass the one that he's not eating eat an
ass does it have to be a girl yeah I
prefer it I don't think he'd care for my
my tastey yeah are there any uh are
there any that might have bonus parts
that show up at your shows like [__]
yeah sure it's got to be bonus mean
everybody had a [__] once in their
lives boy like the attitude bonus part I
never Bon bonus bonus Parts yeah sounds
like a Frank produce sale if you guys
smash at least a thousand girls one them
got your trany that's a lot of
experience in sexual activity how many
girls have you smashed like thousands so
you're saying there's been a few
[__] in there how many I'm not
saying a few but well if if one for
every thousand and you said thousands so
that's at least two what happened one
time when you noticed there's one time
that you knew what happened did you just
let her keep sucking your dick or were
you [__] how did you know who kid I'm
white I know math those was one a you're
not and B no you
don't I mean I remember when I was
really young one of them had one of them
like plastic [__] cuz like they had
the
operation and I figured it out that's
what they get a plastic they didn't get
a real one they make they make Jimmy
how's that work a to be honest you can
feel the difference is R put this guy is
a special of course he's a fck you kid
me I [__] one years but and I didn't
know it was a it was a you could tell it
was a a medically created [__] but I
realized it after it didn't feel the
same it didn't feel the same and it
doesn't get wet it might now though yeah
that was how I knew it was like
something was wrong and I could tell it
was wrong mad lotion you use lotion Cre
what yeah plus I was like what was that
if I want [__] a girl medically created
found two surgical gloves in
it when you figure it out is the worst
feeling ever exactly is it the worst Jim
yeah I didn't that's not what I wanted I
just wanted to [__] woman and I I
wouldn't have cared if I if it did but I
felt it felt different yeah and then it
just your instinct kicks in that there
is something different I mean if she's
preop that's one thing at a boy go for
it do you think that I was like see you
up boy no I wasn't like that that's a
good name right there do you think Waka
could help find uh one of these people
for gim if you found out his rap name
was Big Daddy James oh I forgot about
that yeah that's right big daddy James a
good one put a tweet out yeah I I have
to have a rap pose I'll think my
fingers James you like that that was his
rap name it was stolen by some guy
[__] Connie Kane guy Kane took it in
the 80s Big Daddy James are you sure it
wasn't just uh Little Jimmy thought Big
Daddy Gaine was cool and copied his name
no someone took my name you think I had
drop it yes big daddy James Big Daddy
James B DJ I get I get the best name for
a [__] hip-hop guy nobody's used it
yet what [__]
ghod I don't know g dhod h g [__]
hard be canell it wouldn't it's a great
name it's a great
name money women how's Jihad he's
blowing up son oh that would be such a
big head tell me that's not a good
that's your first mixtape hook kid Jihad
blowing up and here's one for for you
know what a [__] punk band jod is
already one oh you I bet you got it from
me I'm telling you he probably did take
it from you telling you I said it years
ago I didn't know I didn't know Eric and
I didn't know Eric Andre was
A6 a real Jihad out there that's crazy
yeah and I got a great name for like a
punk rock whatever [__] uh crib death
crib death is good yeah how good is
thatal yeah you guys can have that just
give me
peace what's your uh what's your guys
relationship with Ric Flair cuz I saw on
your Instagram hanging with us now he
was on Instagram going woo kid yeah
that's his remix now yeah yeah very very
funny guy so you guys hang with Ric
Flair now all the time it's so weird I
had like [__] awesome we had yogurt
like frozen yogurt you know I'm black I
don't have frozen yogurt I've told
myself that's what it was before too I
understand what is frozen yogurt I never
had that it's yogurt but it's cold it's
delicious it's [__] there's a
place there's a place on Santa Monica
Boulevard called uh oh my God it's it's
called Uh 16 Handles yeah no it's next
to Rage which is a club apparently for
dancing and poppers it's called uh oh
the yogurt stop on Santa Monica BK yurt
me and Jonathan my manager will go there
they think we're a couple the yogurt
stop make a yogurt stop hook best place
on Earth [__] the yogurt stop [__]
rules that's is that a chain thing cuz I
went to one of Gillette is is when you
walk in there's a whole bunch
of you make your own they're all funny
names like they're kind of gay names
like yogurt stop yeah like coming like
you know coming out orange or whatever
all these weird names what they these
gay names and no gay names the Santa
Monica Boulevard they do it it's joke
you go to a gay frozen yogurt shop
there's so many other frozen yogurt
shops it's the place we go to it's
delicious Stadium there was one I is it
a yogurt stop or 16 Handles people I
don't know it was one of those chain
joints that I walk in [__] like soft
best on Earth it was unbelievable ice
cream is better ice cream is better but
I annoyed Bob Kelly one day singing cuz
you know 16 handles is a song so I kept
singing 16 Handles and it really bugged
him that's actually that's actually a
good point who kid Neil you know who he
got mad at me though for some reason did
who did uh Ric Flair because you know I
when I eat ice cream I thought it was
ice cream so I licked it from the side
MH but he said you got to go from the
top that's what Ric Flair said no you
start from the side then you go up and
you say we started I'm going to start at
the bottom but now I'm here but he went
from the top wait wait wait wait wa who
kid what do you have any idea what Jim
just did to you no what nothing I'm just
talking about ice cream he said he's
trying to relate to you what and he cuz
he knows you know you're a hip-hop guy
yeah he's a hipop guy and he said when
you eat your ice cream you go from the
side and you start from the bottom and
now you're here I said no I start I said
you started at the bottom now you here
that's right what's wrong with that
that's a Jill [__] I don't know yeah
what is that [__] Drake song jesz you
guys are getting too deep can't we talk
about The Partridge
Family very upset when they broke up do
I look at my yogurt I said I think I
love
you what am I so afraid of said oh
that's a monkey why why you eat YT come
on get happy I'm a believer I'm doing
the monkeys I'm I used to watch that
show that's how old I what the monkeys
no [__] great wasn't it oh the pit
family I used to jerk off the Susan day
who didn't of course I did well not not
her the other one her on the little
redheaded kid yeah the other one Bon I'm
a little house on a prairie [__]
though sentence I've never heard before
I've always thought that about you Laura
Engles fell down the hill holy [__]
that's right right [__] right there you
know what you know would be a great
podcast listen yeah me and him yeah
exactly I would love to hear I know who
could do uh who could do Little House on
the Prairie uh alternate commentary like
do the director's commentary oh [__]
that [__] fell out of H yeah see you
peace yeah I think so that was sexy
though that was young I never saw that
show little house I didn't watch it I
worked when I was touring with dice he
did a bit about Michael land it was so
[__] brutal cuz he Lov that show when
he got brain cancer as no he had a he
got a colon cancer so that's how Andrew
couldn't remember his name on stage he
goes you know that show with that what's
his name [__]
cancer that's [__] up and then [__]
cancer comes oh my God it's one of the
most brutal bits ever [__]
cancer oh he was funny man oh my God the
Jew with the Rusted pipe
horrible baby the Engles have you [__]
any groupies with Ric Flair uh n hell no
cuz he always I don't know if he's doing
anymore cuz he's so old but he always
tells stories about he used to go on a
how old is he Sam he's pretty [__]
old how old ah that' be like 70
something sneakers those that is pretty
old it's pretty old I can breath again
oh those are nice I would wear those I
have I have typically let me see what
these are not Jordans people thought
mine were Jordans they're not what are
those like Levens I ain't going to wear
those I'm get shot yeah yeah those are
up these look like Jordans but they're
not they do not they do they're [__]
AC Gordons they look like muffins I have
fat muffins those are the ones you let
me tell you something mu they look like
Jordan Marsh that's a who kid muffin you
go out to LA every now and then right y
going on to La Sunday how you you ever
you ever go to a a a a party at a
celebrity residence oh at a mansion I
I've only one celebrity Residence at a
celebrity residence what are we doing at
the Press what the [__] is that you've
been to one a domicile which one was it
have I been more than one oh [__] well
we went to one yes at uh well I didn't
even see her though you didn't see Maria
no I saw her but she was talking to
[__] Michael stra I don't bother her
we went to Maria mano's house for a big
party while we oh my God that [__] is
bad she's my favorite right that's why I
thought so on the [__] planet no one
is sexier than her no one is sexier huh
is she the best she so sexy she comes
out to me at the beach ball she goes I
met you at Comics come home a few years
ago oh she's from Boston right
she I I probably sold cable to her
parents I did I [__] was selling
Cable in Medford yeah how amazing Greek
that [__] is my top she's amazing
that's yeah I'll eat the booty yeah yeah
oh without without a doubt yeah I would
eat the
booty I know her boyfriend I don't want
to say fiance oh she got a f I'll still
eat I mean she's been with him for 19
years Kevin undergaro
yeah Nick just had this look no I got a
great one I'm just saying right right I
got a beautiful married but so like
happily married oh yeah yeah I'm just
saying if I wasn't so we go to this big
uh under if you wasn't you'd eat her ass
after she did a handstand on her period
and
I yeahp we go to the big undergaro Maria
manuno bash and all these people are
there Michael there's a bash Michael
Strahan was there everybody who's
anybody was there but there a big drop
off after that well Jim showed up and if
Cory Feldman was there what that's the
homie right there word him up doc you
got a hot record out too Jim showed up
wearing those shoes so what no one
looked at my feet I mean he's doing him
thank you what a matter with those shoes
he like security guard shoes [__]
someone told me
muffins no you know what it is man I
showed up there and uh I said Sam was
complaining I said we were going to bury
our son why did you care what I had on
my feet I've been complaining about your
[__] shoes all week yeah I know cuz
see is a foot fetish see hard I look at
my toes I I I had knew Jordan on and he
had those on big deal and neither one of
us got laid so there you go I was there
with my wife I got laid no you didn't I
don't know if I got laid that night she
didn't she told me you married yeah how
old are you 33 oh he's a sucker about
right I would I would wear I would wear
who kids shoes though those are nice
like I've never worn a pair of Jordans
maybe I should go get a nice pair of
Jordans which which uh which uh which
which ones are the uh the MJ collection
of those oh shut the [__] up hold on a
second I can't be a little Urban in my
late 40s which MJ what yeah what are
those are those slam dunkers no these
are
the those are nice i' wear those are the
trip here's a good name for a sneaker
triple doubles I wish I the yee the [__]
I'm like a marketing genius I don't like
the Yeezys the Yeezys are ugly let me
see the Yeezys they're [__] terrible
which ones aren't going to get me shot
that's my question uh mine well no
people would kill you just no they would
think you're broke black guys see these
shoes they leave you alone cuz they're
like this guy's no money they shoot you
cuz they're putting you out of your
misery you would have a life that you
would wear those shoes those are some
what the [__] [__] Wier shoes they're
wicker they're ugly they're ug those are
quite honestly 2500 for these terrible
they're hottest shoes in the game right
now I can see how water must beat up on
those in the rain 5,000 for these for
which ones they're like Nerf shoes
people are so dumb they're ugly [__]
love them who wears those everybody
wears the brothers wear those too the
brothers the sisters the whes
rich white kid yeah those are very [__]
shoes rich white kids and rappers look
$112.99 these are the new ones that just
came out who the [__] would pay that ug
look at that it looks like somebody
crushed a [__] guava melon on the
street what an ugly [__] shoe today's
the first day in weeks that make no
sense I'm glad we're on radio what
today's the first day in weeks that H
kid hasn't worn his look at that thing
it looks like
some would a guy in the hood get mad if
you stepped on his Yeezys oh on popping
B it's over I stepped on Yeezys with my
shoes and got mud on his Yeezys oh it's
over look at those [__]
stupid ugly they're not even
functionable exactly I want to sit in
those shoes yeah uh you can get the fake
ones too for like yeah I want to get
yazis what are those fake those are the
ones you just looking at want a of fake
Wick or legit I want a pair of fake
legit I know leg you got to go through
the LC the legit check how what's the
legit check that's when you know where
on the shoe it changes like the fake
ones have certain little things that are
always for my special I'm going to wear
fake Yeezys on purpose you are yes I
want to wear fake Yeezys well I I'll
find out a a place to get some fake
Yeezys for you please tell me but I have
I have problem is I have and I'm going
to tell all the guys in the shop don't
do that what is it the wide I have wide
feet I'm going to tell the fellas listen
guys gang I have wide feet and I have
Orthotics you're not going to find fake
Yeezys on eBay Deb cuz there would be
illegal you wouldn't label them fake
Yeezys go to Harlem and get some fake E
I have very narrow
and that's what I want to wear some
drinis oh my God they only $65 there you
go $68 yalin holy [__] they look Dr
yalini do they look like Yeezys Dr
yalini they do okay I'm going to wear a
nice pair of Dr yalin on my special can
we get him a pair of fake
Yeezys no but I have to try them
on you're not going to go into a shoe
store and get fake they [__] bootleg
yeah exactly sell them somewhere you get
them from a guy all right I want a pair
of I want a pair of Dr
yoginis I'm going to wear a pair I don't
want real Kanye shoes y I want Dr yalis
so VES what size fake Yeezys are you I'm
going to guess an eight um look you up
man okay thank you I don't want the real
ones if Kanye gave them to me I would
wear them but I don't want real Yeezy I
don't like them I want those are nice
the black ones I would wear but not at
that
price 65
$65.99 $66 that's a sensible shoe
exactly right Kanye should release are
these Kanye designs no well the yeah
kany I know Dr yalani cor the market I
think he stole them from Dr yalini I'm a
big Dr yalini Guy um boost 350 running
shoes pirate black with re seven to 10
Dr yalini wonderful I got some NS
slippers that selling on
eBay no Jordans for you huh just fake ye
I wear Jord Jordans are nice and they've
been around for 30 years so yeah those
well those have you got to get Jordan
Ones if you want one if I like if I like
them I rich V will buy them because he
thinks they look younger like I'm I just
like his sneakers I never wanted to wear
Jordans like people look at me and they
think I'm fashionable but they don't
look at my whole outfit I see I see I
would love to see him wearing the the F
real ones they're like 8,000 the Adidas
ones one are those I've seen some but
you can get those fake too I've seen the
there's no fake you know all this
because I like sneakers too you grow up
Detroit [__] he's a fashion no i'
I've seen the I've seen the legit check
videos on the feral there's no white
people that get wear that and look cool
I'm sorry no those aren't those aren't
them the new Fel go flight
club.com Fel sneak what are you doing
this is where if you if you want to get
ripped off you go to this website Flight
Club well they're going to be real
they're going to be legit they're all
real The Fight Club song I mean I mean
store it's here it's on it's in a
village is Harlem in the village they
have real they have all the real stuff
can you try the shoes on go to search
and type for I you can but yes you you
can try thetics I should go down there
and buy a pair of Sak this is still a
radio show right yeah [__] what does
this sound like people listening in
their carss you're examining shoes they
can't see that's right no they're going
to see that AR those aren't them they
look like a fake Nike where's my Dr
yalin I want a pair of Dr yugal there it
is it's the it's the human racean not
those look at that $ that's a sens shoe
that's a nice sh tampon yes come on try
my used Rags bucks 450 that's a sensible
shoe that's a shoe I'd wear on P didy
yacht you know on New Year's Eve and St
Barts that's not that bad I mean 450 is
a lot of money for a shoe but I mean I I
would wear that you can handle it my
agent bought me a pair by the way a
beautiful my my stupid agent Bob eatman
had a pair of shoes on that were great
and I told him how much I like him he
sent me a pair is he a radio agent yes
it's like $650 shoes I've never paid
that much for a shoe in my life well for
yourself um you know what I think that's
what it uh signified New Deal coming up
Jimbo I have my uh my Jordan top three
is coming in the mail tomorrow oh
snappies um I but I would wear a nice P
I'm going to go to that place Flight
Club is there a line uh can I go in
definitely yeah you can go in there's no
line what what are you pointing at oh
that's my [__] who is it doesn't Kid
Rock have some sandals or something like
yeah Kid Rock actually did come out with
some boots though really carart makes
them I think oh good some Cowboy [__]
some stomping boots I'm wearing lemy
[Laughter]
ugs we should take a break hook you got
to go interview Bill Bellamy right yeah
whatever bill I actually know Billy do
you we did the Young comedian special
together back in the early 50s is that
bill was it no I think it was his video
guy oh okay yeah I don't doesn't
remember me I don't think he remembers
me but we did I told the story before
the worst show of my life was when Bill
Bellamy was hosting and it was in a
black club and called uh Club 88 in East
Orange i b why would you go there 1993
when when did Rod King get beaten why
the [__] would you go on there I was
doing a gig and Bob Levy was killing I
mean I bombed horribly ly was killing of
course I was doing so badly after Rodney
King meeting it wasn't that long after
yeah um when it was it 91 yeah it was
probably like you not long after so
there was still racial tension and then
Bob's asked the guy what he did for
living the guy's like I'm a cop and
Bob's like why don't you take a club and
beat your self and it iced the room I
mean he that didn't work it was right no
it was right after that it was just so
what I'm just telling it was you know he
was killing up until then he ice that's
where they draw the line well not you
know 25 years ago you can hear uh DJ who
kid every Saturday at what at noon uh
yeah whenever I get whenever you get
there every Saturday uh for most of
Saturday over on Shade 45 12 to 6 uh you
get to hear interviews and uh some of
the newest hip hop
hits as it
wereas also if you want to hear a
podcast all about about some joints man
yeah Nick talo is playing all the Hip
Hop joints on his call joints now on my
CD I gotta get Nick on the show man the
Nick depalo podcast is on iTunes and
it's at connectpal.com Nick and Nick
too.com is his website